[Music]
[Applause]
so boiling oil didn't happen
sorry i mean you can just throw boiling
water
hi my name is roko naidak i'm a lecturer
in ancient history at the university of
oxford i'm an expert in ancient warfare
and i'm here to talk to you today about
pre-modern warfare in wonder movies
so this is this supposed greek concept
of
moss which it literally means pushing
and about 100 years ago a scholar in
oxford who clearly had rugby on his mind
decided that this should be conceived as
a literal mass shoving we have no
evidence of that nobody ever says that
that's the case but for some reason this
really caught on and so for the last
hundred years has been controversial but
generally speaking i mean people didn't
want to fight like that spears are right
in your face
so there's a lot of of reasons to want
to avoid this
so this moment where they switch from
fighting information to going after
individuals who are still resisting that
seem very realistic for most of these
fights make sure you can kill as many of
them as possible because that's when
they're vulnerable that's when they're
not fighting back so that's when you can
just sort of spear them in the back and
that's exactly what happens in this
scene it's only very much later in
spartan history where they say we don't
chase
uh the fleeing enemy because if you
chase the enemy then you're caught out
of formation you become vulnerable but
at this at this time in the time of the
persian war so the spartans had no rules
against this and indeed it's a true
story you can't really dispute that but
in sense of
the tactics and the weapons it feels
like a fantasy movie maybe three or four
out of ten
if the old man's in range why isn't
everybody shooting they're making all
these people on the walls hold their
arrow for a really long time and these
are really heavy bows so it's exhausting
and pointless
plate armor is intended to keep arrows
out bows aren't guns they are meant as
suppressive weapon you use it to keep
their heads down and so of course you
would still use it even against people
wearing plate armor because even the
feel of of arrows sort of pinging off
your armor or falling around you is
going to make you much more cautious and
hesitant
obviously attacking walls with ladders
is just a really really risky
proposition and usually doesn't work if
you believe they don't have either the
courage or the
strength to resist you then you might
try this you just put a lot of ladders
against the walls swarm up take the
place
if you expect it to be defended it's it
puts you in such a position of
vulnerability approaching the walls one
at a time and then it's just not going
to go well but obviously it is a very
common tactic i mean you can go to the
british museum right now and see
depictions of people assaulting walls
with ladders
yeah so i mean the problem when you see
this kind of siege scenes in movies that
they always seem to make it really easy
for the attacker if they want to go
right up to the wall they can just do
that if they want to bring siege engines
if they want to bring catapults or rams
or towers up to the walls they can just
do that it's like they're trying to make
it possible for this place to fall
whereas in reality i mean one of the
most common forms of fortification is
very simply if you have the ground like
this you dig a ditch
and you pile up the sand behind it then
you build your wall on top of that
and now what do you have the enemy wants
to approach you from the front they end
up in the ditch suddenly the wall
they're facing is much higher if they
want to bring siege towers or battering
rams they fall into the ditch they would
have to fill up the ditch first before
they can get to you all that time
they're right under your walls
in movies they never do this because
that would slow things down i want to
keep the assault engaging that's why a
lot of the tactics that they show you
are actually
too simple and and missing a lot of the
points that would actually be used
[Music]
well firstly that hill is much too steep
so everybody would die but
these horses would just slide to their
deaths unfortunately um but if we
if we take that out of the equation
um i always thought it
it was validated by the fact that he
uses the light of the sun to blind the
orcs which means they lower their pikes
at the last moment so the idea is that
he creates those openings that the
horses need to see in order to push
their charge so you see them sort of
wavering and breaking just before the
charge hits which is exactly the point
like that makes it conceivable that this
could have worked i mean it is still a
fantasy and they're doing many things
wrong on the other hand
it certainly hits a number of points
where you're like well this is realistic
using sort of layered of initiative in
order to overcome the defenses yeah i
mean four out of ten five out of ten
[Music]
this is just
just wrong i mean
[Applause]
i mean what are they doing here like
this is where are they getting the idea
that the scots in this period were
wearing like leather and war paint like
these
these are just like ordinary medieval
infantry they would be wearing chain
mail and helmets like this you know they
just deliberately made them into savages
why would you make them into savages
they're sophisticated people
they had disciplined pike formations
it's so bizarre
so fire arrows are not entirely
unhistorical they did exist but usually
you would use them during a siege
assault for instance like you could use
them to set things on fire which is what
they're for so buildings and you know
stocks and supplies wood and straw
thatch roofs because it would create
chaos and distractions
this idea of involving fire in battle
scenes is just something that hollywood
loves i mean you just want to have fire
because it's a nice spectacle
also how would they have done this
without the english noticing that there
was a field of oil or something on the
ground like they wouldn't have like been
like oh that's probably there for no
reason i'm just going to stand in front
of it
[Applause]
[Music]
they just do this every all these movies
they just sort of charge into each other
like horses lancers they just sort of
match into each other like no regard for
anything
and then like when people ask me like so
in a battle like this like how would you
know which one is on which side like how
would you know who to stab basically
like yeah you wouldn't obviously if it
went down like this you would have no
idea which is why it didn't
as soon as your formation gets so
messed up and so disorderly that the
enemy are in your ranks you know you've
lost now you would infantry would often
charge into battle in the sense that it
would run the last distance
to meet the enemy because everybody's
afraid nobody wants to be there really
because they know they're about to be
mortal danger so you run and you scream
to get yourself through that point and
to psych yourself up and to know that
there's a lot of you who are all in it
together
but then you probably by the best modern
theories you slow down when you get to
the enemy
and then you would start stabbing at
each other in more or less even lines
because otherwise everything would just
you would just lose control this is a
joke i mean like
i from the from the equipment to the
tactics like none of this has any
bearing on what actually happened except
that
william wallace was defeated that's
basically
two out of ten or one out of ten
that's that's one of the most common
forms of ancient artillery is these bolt
shooters they would shoot these big rods
these sort of metal metal bolts they're
very effective
they shoot further and more accurately
than arrows
there's an account of somebody getting
you know blown off his feet and pinned
to a tree by one of these things they
are very useful in siege because again
they clear the walls you don't want to
stand there
i mean what is the point here this this
forest is clearly very wet it's not
going to burn
it just looks
cinematic
and they form a test tutor of course
they do
i mean it's not ridiculous i mean the
romans did have a formation like that
it's called testudo
and they did use it in a few occasions
and when you knew you had to pass
through a bunch of arrow fire and you
didn't want to
lose any casualties but it's a desperate
measure so then you're stuck waiting
essentially for the enemy just to stop
shooting at you
so in in a battle situation you wouldn't
want to
waste your time trying to get into that
formation and then waste your time
trying to get out of it again when the
enemy's right there
instead you would just try to get
through that zone and get into the thick
of it
do not be trouble
oh you are an elysium
and you're already dead it's an endless
debate whether those speeches actually
happened because it's hard to speak to
an entire army full of people especially
without a microphone
but
it is something that is very very common
in descriptions of battles so we the
best we can do is assume that they did
happen and that they were very important
part of it
[Music]
so the cavalry here bizarrely
charges through a forest
this is
a really bad idea your horses are going
to break their legs
like you wouldn't you try to find open
ground i mean it uses a lot of
actual roman tactics and equipment so i
guess 6 out of 10 but
it's a mishmash
the whole point is just that they're
just doing saving private ryan it's just
made up because they wanted to have a
scene like saying proud ryan resisted
landings are not common in ancient
warfare because they're very
they're kind of a modern warfare thing
most of the time they would just find a
suitable beach somewhere
a reasonable distance away from their
target and land there and then they
would advance on their targets
these are just stakes for show who are
they gonna stop like they're not trying
to to land tanks here or anything people
can just walk through them like if you
want to fortify anything in antiquity in
the middle ages in the modern day ditch
and a palisade it's that simple it's
easy all you need is a bit of wood and
some shovels and they haven't done it
they just put some stakes up here and
there for for no reason just kind of
sprinkle some stakes
[Music]
this kind of shield formation is is
total rubbish i mean come on there's
there's nothing like that in greek
history they're not going to be like
this overlapping sort of turtle thing
[Music]
in the period where this poem is set
there was no mounted cavalry and even in
later periods you rarely have people
actually fighting on horsebacks it's
hard to work out how to use cavalry
tactically
it's difficult to use it if you don't
have very many of them
and horses are just very precious it
costs an enormous amount of money to
maintain a horse so you don't want to
waste your horse on something like this
guy and his hammer
it's charging all together they have no
sense of order and in fact if you look
closely in one of these scenes
just to the left of paris after the next
shot of paris running away i think
the extra falls down on his face
i mean i love that because it just shows
exactly why you wouldn't want to be
doing this right because if everybody's
running all together
um
you're just going to trip over yourself
like everybody's gets in each other's
way like they're doing a beach landing
which is obviously inspired by an
earlier movie um it has nothing to do
with history except that they have
swords and arrows uh yeah me what do you
want two out of ten
so again where is your ditch where's
your ditch
you've gotta have a ditch otherwise
they're gonna run those siege towers
right up to your wall you know this and
obviously jerusalem at the time did have
a ditch and it had a pre-wall in another
ditch
so that you can't just put your
siege engines right up to the wall
of course they start throwing fireballs
stopping with the fireballs
admittedly it is realistic here that
they are very concerned about not like
trying to keep their siege weapons from
catching fire the defenders would try to
set them on fire and so it's very
important to protect them from that
usually by
covering them with wet hides
[Music]
so boiling oil is a big trope right you
see in a lot of movies it's not a thing
didn't happen
sorry so there's there's no evidence of
it ever happening there's no description
of people being being smothered in
boiling oil certainly not oil that's
already been set on fire i mean you can
just throw boiling water and it does the
same thing which is hurt people or you
can just throw rocks but they cost you
nothing they take no preparation and you
just
you throw them at people they get hurt
it's it's great so
boiling oil is just needlessly elaborate
and you're burning fuel you don't want
to be burning things for no good reason
in the account that we have the siege it
says there is constant fighting outside
the walls and there were also assaults
on the walls this one's better than the
other one actually better than helms
deep
again they should have been digging
ditches literally all they do is just
stand around carrying like spears from
one point to another you should be
digging ditches many ditches once your
first stitch is ready build another one
the female characters other than the
ones who've been trained to fight are
basically just sort of hiding in the
dungeon and not doing anything
in actual sieges especially when it was
this desperate i mean they would just be
expected to contribute you know women
children old men everybody does
something because there's always things
that people can do even when they don't
fight you know go and carry arrows and
stones up to the people on the walls and
put out fires you know help with
with water and food help with clothing
and the wounded there's no way you would
just stick them away in a corner
somewhere
these catapults are obviously in the
wrong place they should be on top of the
wall like why would you put them outside
of the walls they're going to be overrun
you can't move them out of the way
quickly enough so put them on top of the
wall that's where you put your artillery
so you can put your cavalry in front and
it totally works
if you don't expect your enemy to stand
their ground so putting your cavalry in
front is a time tested you know very
common strategy totally works unless
you're fighting ice zombies who are not
going to break and they're not scared of
you you're just wasting your cavalry so
it's it's the right tactic for the wrong
moment there are probably several
battles in other battles in game of
thrones where this could have worked
really well should you find yourself
fighting an army of ice zombies so put
your artillery on the wall dig many
ditches
just lots and lots of ditches um you can
put of course your infantry in front if
you want to confront them there because
that means that you will have several
stages to fall back on after that you
won't sort of blow everything all in one
go
but put your cavalry away from
the main line so that once the enemy is
engaged
once your ice zombies are stuck against
your line you can then swoop in from the
side where they're not expecting you and
overrun them i mean it's not going to
really necessarily win your fight
against an army of ice zombies but at
least it means that you are fighting
them in a way that they don't expect at
least you will have done something with
your recovery that made sense but
otherwise i mean obviously it's all a
bit silly so
what should we say five out of ten
[Music]
i mean this movie had an oxford
professor advising only uh on the movie
you can see all little details that they
got you know in terms of their dress in
terms of their their tactics and
maneuvers like all of this is is as good
as we can get it almost it's really you
know
really precise except for
the fact that for the persian army they
still went with this kind of slightly
racist
depiction of you know
flimsy warriors wearing eyeliner and
things like that it doesn't really
reflect reality at this point there
would have been much more organized and
much more heavily equipped but this is
just the way that people like to depict
persia in general and the the east
which is just yeah it leaves a bad taste
in your mouth
in fact throughout this period the
greeks
were the ones who fought like that
whereas the persians were known to be
much more organized and to advance
silently into battle which was something
that the greeks were really impressed by
[Music]
camels always useful because they scare
horses it's kind of a theme throughout
persian history that we use camels to
scare off enemy cavalry
[Music]
with this movie like all the equipment
is just right like these guys you know
these are the companions you know later
on they're going to be some thracians
like you can pinpoint very exactly who
they are
um the the whole pike phalanx is exactly
depicted accurately with all of the
the weaponry and the spacing between the
men and the kind of blocks in which they
maneuver and things like that
now this is obviously a bit silly people
wouldn't deliberately impale themselves
on a giant stick it's much more likely
that they would just sort of stop before
stop in front of that and start falling
back and you don't actually expect a big
pike formation to actually kill a lot of
people because people don't you know
they try not to die
they're going to run away from it
i mean this is exactly as it says in the
source this is our best reconstruction
of how this battle happens this is you
know in terms of ancient warfare this is
the most accurate depiction that you'll
find anywhere and i would give this 9
out of 10.
[Music]
stop no
where are your missiles no this is where
these battles they would be they would
be about trying to disrupt the formation
not sort of to slam into it and hope it
goes away
i mean you'd be throwing you're shooting
arrows at it and throwing javelins at it
to try and see if you can create some
gaps in it and then eventually once you
saw a weak spot you might sort of rush
forward and so you could use your swords
and your spears um to try and create a
hole in the shield walls it doesn't do
any it doesn't achieve anything
[Applause]
yeah no vikings would definitely use
shield walls i mean that aspect of it is
realistic except the fact that it's a
three-layered shield wall seems a bit
excessive
that's a roman formation
but you do have you know obviously
viking shield walls are are the way they
would fight pitch battles when they did
so they would try to avoid pitch battles
and mostly would fight in surprise
attacks ambushes and sieges so this is a
rare occasion where according to this
scene apparently they actually had
numerical superiority so then they could
risk it and so this one i would probably
give like six or seven out ten
and so
this movie is entirely based on the
romance so not on the historical record
it's essentially just a fantasy story
this formation
in this circle record there is something
called the eight gates formation which
does isn't described it means a really
elaborate infantry formation that has
these sort of changing shifting shield
walls
which is intended to trap enemy cavalry
and so that's what you're seeing
happening here is that they are using
shifting shield walls to trap enemy
cavalry there are a couple of
descriptions of it happening in a sort
of competitive maneuvering
where two armies are trying to show that
they have more control and more
discipline by competitively moving
troops around
but actually there is no evidence that
it was ever used in a battle to defeat
anyone it's it's it's much too complex
the amount of control that you would
need over every individual detachment
the amount of coordination of each
single man everybody has to know exactly
where he has to stand for it for this to
work and none of them can you know even
a stray arrow killing one of them would
disrupt this entire formation because it
would create a gap in it
so it's just it's just not feasible that
seems sort of wildly optimistic as to
the abilities of any infantry force
in real life if you could get that close
to calvary why not just stab them it's
another one of those things that is
based on a story so how can you judge it
you know like it's it's cool it's
evocative but it's it's not historical
it's got the equipment right so maybe
four